vous avez été récompensés hier soir
c'est une belle récompense paulo une
belle reconnaissance
bon c'est le besoin surtout que laisser
le prix du public
nous on va penser donc c'est un plaisir
pour tout sinon olympique a travaillé et
puymoyen
il ya d'autres cas travail à donkey car
travail et punir nautica travail et
surtout le public les audits et qui
captait nous tous les après midi entre 4
d'après midi précisé qu'ali connaître
que yo landi démission talent a donc pas
penser et c'est peut-être pour ça que
c'est maintenant appelée vivoter money
ou qassam sag étaient surpris rouissi
véritables bons ou pas ou pathé live
layori med pria mais bon vous les gars
c'est ça qui était si bas c'est au prix
là yoann ans sb oui parce que il a
plaisamment baup en août en compétition
et puis des déchets tri des déchets
reçus ces prix quand même geci à l'âme
et l'utica travail en pire et puis le
bal des ponts cannelle et puis en bas
quelques regrets mais en pire
c'est des glaces l'asloca il voulait pas
simplement obligé pâti pendant réception
et puis à priori moins d'une c2 nous
quittera pessah donc moi tu es content
qu'on m'ait pas ses douves angers 6 et
puis des dessins plupart entre colons ma
réaction
l'ajustement et c'est l'occasion pour
saluer ses mômes est à l'application de
travail j'ai su qu'il n'avait fini très
souvent dans l'abordage à nous demander
beaucoup de mu la ddc prix ben lui même
a démissionné en mai indicatif lassé des
éléments décomposait mais également
celles qui composent et musique là au
départ s'étaient fait sauter la fontaine
kit est composé medic laménie aussi
vaisseau vous allez andy dans indicatif
- et puis cela est vraiment et ses
glaces la visio cas alors est ce que
qu'a pensé que à présent qu'à fait
partie du patrimoine matinik sé à nou lé
pa moin émission émission distribution
ils sont bombardés pour une matinée que
la peau dure parce que sarah montrait
que c'est mon autre bizuth et ça c'est
mon nom brisées des bagarres qui cassent
en mieux et dans la bretelle s'il n'aura
pas les français nous rabat les
cueilleurs espagnol nous matinée pied
dont quels que soient menés à nuuk aiea
émission qu'on s'est fait le plus
souvent pour casser non vraiment
méconnaître coolio a dit dans sa cave
enterrée et puis marquer ce géo après
mission après journal en français gentil
jaune avant que je ne vous dis pas
est-ce que ou k et ses admissions talent
a dit mme était justement en valeur tous
acquis car cette matinée qui étaient
tous à matignon a proposé tous acquis
patrimoine matinik réellement absolument
parce que parmi tous ces moments là
qu'ils y auraient compté cela il dément
mais que nous avons sauvées nous avec
ayew fait des émissions qu'on l'esprit
de la sotefi mission tice grave
les avirons nous allons les yoyos la
même elle a pratiquement toutes ces
moments et talents auquel ben youb a en
pris nous ne comptons pas ce que nous
qualifions l'a pourtant grand ouvert à
chaque fois pour défendre une tendinite
hier à l'abordage en l'émission
martinique la première a retrouvé depuis
quatre ans pour 6 4 tous les quatre à
quatre heures du matin uni lionel et
puis comme claudine délicat la première
à l'abordage félicitations mais s'ils
veulent encore une fois ce que vous
veniez puis trophée ne s'est pas arrêté
là
merci beaucoup pour la sauver en tunique
la première et télé spectateurs aussi